now remember when I was young they had
we played basketball on a select group
in the in a really budget basketball
team and after practice sometime the
coach would drive us home you know - if
you had if the pay if your mom had a
little bit of money or she had maybe a
Toyota Camry or maybe a arm you know a
van or something like that something
nice your mother come get you scoop you
up from the practice but the remainder
of us children would our coach would
give us a ride home so you hop in a
coach's truck or you hopping the coaches
oh he had a van but an arm ladder on the
back you know and it didn't go anywhere
but you know it's nice it is kind of you
know it was nice to have and anyway
you know you get to know the coach well
when he drives you home from practice
and sometimes he would take us to do
stuff you know he would take us to help
him do some work for him giving us those
rides so one weekend he he drove us out
into the country somewhere - we were
helping him move something unloading
things into a truck or something it was
me and this young fella
boo-boo Tyson and this was a black
gentleman and his name was boo-boo Tyson
and and his brother had tried to burn
his legs off but he he didn't he still
had his legs he didn't you know he it
didn't happen you know and he had one
leg that was a little hot you know but
he was he was fine and he was a friend
of mine and we're driving along this
road one time and on a highway me and
him in the back of the truck and
maybe they had a you know a lawnmower
back there or a little
canteen of diesel or something you know
maybe a jug of sipping water or
something back there with it and we
drove probably in the back of this
little truck this little Japanese truck
maybe a Korean truck locate truck
Daihatsu or something or you know shout
sue or some kind of little just a little
truck man
it sounded like under the hood they had
about 7,000 Korean people just you know
just strain and hard to keep it going
you know one of them little shy zot
Sue's or something you know what I'm
talking about
a little truck and and we've been going
along the highway and you know and
boo-boos are looking at me and he's
looking at me and he just starts kind of
just really looking at me kind of funny
and at one point the highway came to a
stop sign or intersection with another
highway and so coach was driving and
we're sitting in the back of the in the
open cab and he said to me he said hey
he said hey do what's it like to have
your hair blow in the wind and I'd never
thought about that you know because he
had a high tight fade cut and and I'd
never thought about that man and I said
man what's it like to have your penis
blow in the wind and and we died
laughing man the two of us just died
laughing and and man it was
I don't know I saw there's some I miss
being young man I really miss being
young let's go
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch and
my mom is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
now I'm just floating on the breeze and
I feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be cornerstone oh when I reach that
feel it in my mouth it's gonna change
the little time we will set that parking
brake and let my cell phone wire
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you my story
and I will find a song I will sing it
just good to be here I am I had me a
little London broil shout out london
shout out england you know for getting
meats over here we're just getting
through to core of it and everybody's
you don't know what's gonna come in and
you see the articles you see the article
in the news say hey meats gone no more
meat all the meat you know spoiled all
the meat fell off a boat you know birds
buzzards stole the meat they just
everyday something else happened the
chain to meet chain it's done there were
there will no you will never see any
mall meat and then BAM here we are you
know one week after the disease is if
whoever was a disease whatever I don't
know one week after it's gone and in
London's hooking us up with that hearty
rump hit or bra that shank because it's
you know it's just nice to have so shout
out of England shoutout UK for getting
us those meats over here had that London
brawl set that thing up in that crock
pot mmm gotta cry you know in a head I
had this is my second crock pot the
first one too small you could barely do
two Bacon's in it you almost had to do
one bacon at a time and because first
time I tried you know I was using my
crock
I threw about maybe nine pieces and
bacon in there and I left I went and
drove around for a couple hours I wanted
to see if the thing worked and I come
back
and uh and it just hadn't really it had
done a little bit at the bottom so then
I realized damn I need one slice at a
time in this little bastard it was just
like a dam he would like the pot on it
was so small it was like somebody it was
like one person's kind of medium hand in
a cup like cupped up like they trying to
sip water to you know give a little
water to a dog or something with their
hand make a make a shape like a little
baby like half a banana with their hand
and give a dog that moisture but anyway
now I got that now I got a real just a
dam a bathtub for some meat so I threw
that London in there you know through
some some couple PO tots
some of them orange uh you know veg
veggies there's phalanges bruh those
beta carotenes brother and kirat son put
them in that pot and let that bad
bastard do its work what else um
I'll watch the fights this weekend
not on the news on not on or on Twitter
on total UFC I watched the UFC it was it
was enjoyable shout out sugar Shawn out
there busting them down hitting him with
the freakin straight-up glucose to the
chin bruh oh I enjoyed watching uh
Cody stamen to young fellah and it was
just so sad he had lost his brother oh
the week before and and he was fighting
Brian I think killer her and I thought
he showed him a ton of respect as well I
mean just a you know both of those guys
but man to get out there and fight after
you know just a family tragedy to be
able to have still show up for yourself
and for your team and and for your
brother's spirit I thought it was
it was really touching man it was real
real touching what else is going on not
not you know everything really or
nothing or you know we're back in
business
it seemed like they got some restaurants
open and you know they've you know this
whole this past weekend was a lot of you
know a lot of unrest in the media in the
news and and we had a lot of voicemails
about it and I want to talk about some
of it and and and you know I want to say
if you if you come to this podcast and
you you know if you were you know this
isn't like a controversial type of place
here
you know if you come here listening to
you know oh what Theo is gonna say
something wrong or we're gonna catch
this is that you know it's a type of
environment where people are you know
you know where I'm gonna prove to him my
point or something like that man yeah
I'm not I I don't have any answers I
don't have any answers you know and um
and I don't know how people can a
hundred percent have an answer you know
because the time is really time is kind
of a long question
so if you you know but I'm just saying
if you you know and I look there's a lot
of great people in here and just I don't
know I've just gotten a lot of social
media comments and stuff this past
weekend and if you I don't know if you
come in here to say oh I know better
than you or you don't know or this that
you've already won
I'm not trying to be right you know I'm
trying to be alive I'm trying I'm trying
to stay in contact with with life I
think and stay in contact with just the
long question that is life you know and
this show you know everybody's welcome
on this show you know you could be
Arabic you could be you know you could
be homosexual you could be in a
wheelchair you could be from Spain you
could be black you could be uh you know
what else you could be a spirit you
could be a vapor
I don't you could be anything Native
American on Native American you know you
could be whatever you want you could be
tired you could be menthol anything you
could be somebody who welded their legs
together on accident and shop and now
has to play a mermaid every year you
know in a local play everybody's welcome
here man you know I just want to let you
know that you could be anything you know
Spanish Mexican Latino latina you know
latina latina v dad you know that female
Christmas baby you could be anything and
you welcome here man you know that but
yeah a lot going on out there and uh and
so yeah thank you guys for showing up a
lot of people had calls that came in
about it
and so I want to get to some of it get
to some of those calls man and just kind
of talk about what people are talking
about a little hear of people's points
of views and what's my experience been
like this past weekend you know I had a
rough instance we um you know the rat
Ken came to visit because obviously you
know your boy Tom sug
your boy Tom sugar night over there is
uh he wanted some and so he got some you
know because that's how it is sometimes
if you want some then you get some you
know knock knock who's there some
because that's what she's bouts to get
and and I'm on Twitter the other day and
and I didn't know how bad I mean I I
mean Twitter is just a it's obviously a
real cess hole and you know I see Drew
Brees in there cuz I follow all saints
stuff and so Drew Brees comes up in my
feet and so us I'll click on the video
and I'm doing something and next thing
you know I hear Brees talking about how
he supports the American flag so I share
it you know I retweet it put some strong
arms with it and just retweet it well
you know we're doing work about an hour
later I get a text from Brendan Schaub
you know or baskin-robbins whatever
people call them different nicknames and
he says hey man people are upset about
your tweet and so I look at it and and I
didn't realize that that drew brees had
been talking about people's reaction to
Colin Kaepernick Nealon you know I I
didn't watch the question from the guy
in the beginning from Yahoo which I
don't I do not like I used to work for
Yahoo but I don't like their website man
I think it's a bunch of garbage but
but anyway next thing I know I look on
there and it's like oh man people people
that I know are just dragging me through
the mud just dragging me through the mud
man and um and it was just kind of crazy
you know and so I just took my tweet
down you know I didn't feel like dealing
with I didn't feel like dealing with it
you know I watch the video fully that
drew brees head up and I thought man he
he could have expressed himself
differently who knows if he heard the
question fully he's over you know the
things over Skype or zoom you know I
don't know he you know he could have
probably expressed his answer
differently but people were ripping him
a new head and I had no idea you know
I'm a Saints fan I see Drew Brees he's
talking about supporting the flag and so
I share um you know that's where I'm at
that's where I'm at with it I didn't
know I didn't know it was in correlation
to Colin Kaepernick etc anyway so next
thing you know there's just so much
hateful stuff people that I know just
ripping me up and so I just realize man
I'm some of this social social media
stuff is just it's too much you know
it's not a place where you can converse
I thought about saying oh you know I'm a
Saints fan and you know I just saw the
part where he said that he's excited you
know that he respects the flag and why
he likes and why he supports it but
people don't want there's no there's no
discussion on Twitter and there's really
probably it's really tough to discuss
anything anywhere on social media
there's really not a lot of discussion
there's not a lot of conversation you
know I had another rough experience this
week everybody's posting black squares
and this was and people say well you
could stand you know you can fight for
yourself in this and that oh I'm not
gonna I just don't want to spend all day
doing that you know I don't want to
in a place where I can't just where
there's no conversation you know I grew
up my whole childhood not knowing how to
express myself or when I could or what
you know when it was okay to talk you
know or have feelings about something or
how to express them and I'm still not
great at it and but to be in a vacuum
where you can't even raise your hand
that's what it feels like it feels like
you're like Twitter feels like a place
you can't even raise your hanging so
anyway so then the same thing a similar
thing kind of happened with the black
square people put up the black square
and and I put up the black square and I
felt you know I support black lives
matter I support any lives matter I
support everybody's life you know I I
felt bad because it became this thing
where everybody's doing it you know when
I started looking at people that I
admire Sutter people that I admire doing
this do I need to do this is this a real
thing I don't know you know I don't know
I don't know what to do and I probably
should have just done nothing because I
don't like to be forced to you know I
like to be unique you know I was trying
to think of a way how can I support my
black friends and support black
community and support the fight the fact
that I don't think that anybody should
struggle at the hands of police
brutality and I realized that that's
what I didn't like about the black
square is that it didn't give me a
chance to be unique it didn't give me a
chance to be you know kind of find a
unique way to express myself and then I
got messages from people from people of
color I don't know if that's the right
term telling me that I'd done it wrong
that I didn't do the right hash tagging
and so I just said screw it man I'm not
dealing with this [ __ ] I'm not dealing
with something where you have to get it
like you can't even have any your a
millimeter off from the exact way
something supposed to be done and you
didn't and you're wrong it just didn't
rest well with me man and um so that's
kind of you know how I ended up feeling
about a lot of the social media stuff
had a lot of people I asked me about it
you know and I'm not gonna argue with
the with the lady I'm not gonna argue
with you know I don't know I don't like
feeling forced I don't like feeling
forced I like to try and be unique so
those were just some of my thoughts I'm
not saying that those thoughts are right
I'm not saying that you have to do
anything or you don't just kind of
telling you what happened with me that
was kind of my experience and it upset
me that people that I knew didn't call
me to say hey man this dude you don't
understand what's going on here like
this you know people are upset because
of this or it didn't they just like just
hung me out to dry like they were trying
to use me to get their clout up their
online clout up and that hurt my
feelings man so I just said I don't have
to say anything but then you see stuff
that says silence is I don't even know
it just became so impossible it just
made me realize the best way for me to
be involved is to be involved in
practices in my life that this stuff
online a lot of this stuff is it's not
even for a movement it's for the
individual sometimes it
for people trying to look a certain way
that's even why we don't when I thought
about it too about the black square my
yes I support black lives now I would
never want to see anybody hurt you know
so I called my friends I called my
friends that are black that's what I did
and I spoke with them and I heard their
voices and I talked with them and I let
him know that I love them
that's what I did I think guys about
four guys that I spoke to and and it was
nice man it was nice it was nice to know
that on her in a real place in a
one-on-one connection place everything
was pretty comfortable and so that's
right you know that's really what I've
been doing and I know a lot of people
had a lot of different thoughts you know
but I spoke to my friends that's what I
spoke to them and and I enjoyed it him
you know there was some laughter there
was some you know touching moments and
just checking in with each other you
know that's kind of so that's sort of
how you know this is a tumultuous
weekend for a lot of people and again
I'm not telling you how to live your
life or do anything but I am saying that
this podcast is a place where people can
communicate and it's not you could raise
your hand here you know this isn't a
place where you're not allowed to speak
or to think or to feel you know because
I don't want it to be that for me you
know I was scared to even do this
episode a little bit I'm scared to talk
about some of this kind of stuff because
so many people you get one word wrong
you're going to hell you're doing this
you with the devil now boy you hate
black people you hate leopards somebody
said you hate leopards if you don't get
this right what the [ __ ] are you talking
about huh you know just I just just um I
just don't want to play that game I
don't want to live in that gown I don't
want to live in that space and that's
the space that's created online a lot
you know when I got out of there and I
got into the real humanity and checked
in with my friends things were it was it
was a lot safer than that then in the
world where they want you to believe
that everything is is a verklempt you
know we're lopsided or that the whole
world has flat tires on it that that
every human heart is rolling around with
a flat tire on it I don't believe that
you guys had some thoughts man let's get
into a couple of them sorry to be
serioso on here
but sometimes you know [ __ ] hit you bruh
sometime you running down the block and
a turd catches you in the net you know
and that's God just wanted to give you a
a couple comments about our current
environment thank you for calling Mike I
appreciate a man home word perspective
from a police officer up here in
California a man first of all I just
want to say that uh you know what took
place out in Minneapolis with this
officer it's pretty disturbing and I'll
tell you on behalf of everyone I know in
the law enforcement community that's
just not how we do business
you know we we're governed by strict
policies and procedures that guide how
we have to use force against somebody
that's combative
and I'll tell you man under most
circumstances we try to use the least
amount of force as possible for every
given situation oh yeah brother LF maybe
least force baby homework our goal is
definitely not to to hurt anybody but
unfortunately those things happen and
it's just that now that uh you know that
we take a hit on that on one guys action
our whole law enforcement family have to
take a hit on that I guess the most
important thing and the message I really
want to get out there madness that's
just that's just not who we are
there you go right there and that's an
adult man right there that's an adult
male police officer I'm assuming could
also be female you do not know a hundred
percent I don't want to jump to
conclusions but it could be Mike you
know female might miss Mike but thank
you for the call yeah I'm sure that's
really tough you know you applied for a
job you're part of a group you know it's
just I mean it's heartbreaking when one
person ruins things for people you know
it's heartbreaking and um and that's got
to be tough man it's got to be tough for
you as well you know being on you know
being at a job where you have to go out
and you're you know your responsibility
is so much heavier then somebody that's
going to do electricity is pretty that's
that's pretty hardcore whenever you know
you know voltage is basically to burgle
right there and that shit's about this
trying to steal your soul every time you
around a cable but yeah like somebody
that works at the pool or somebody that
works at a arm Derry you know they got
an easier path then then then a police
officer minim thank you for the call
Mike and thank you for thank you for
your service man let's take another call
here here we go
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three hey what a do PEO with you
boy Kenny from the park what's up Kenny
from the beach baby sandcastle Kenny Sun
drawbridge Kenny down there babysitting
them beauties in them a leg got Thor's
baby them Spanish I like that but Baba
homeward you know obviously a lot of
people think it's white versus black it
was not put in actuality you know it's
cop versus people of color people of
oppression and whatnot so a lot of
people like to come back like blue lives
matter like okay black lives matter you
know stuff like that but they're trying
to make it seem like blue lives like
cops are a race like they wake up blue
like they are Smurfs or something you
know what I'm saying how the Smurfs out
here aim speaking of which the Smurfs
Loki I think with the racist TV show
because if you looked at all the same
color no wearing white hood Papa Smurf
man you got the red hood on okay but
that's a whole different boy oh yeah
they're acting like you know cops are a
race they don't wake up black you know
they don't wake up ground they don't
wake up Latino Hispanic you know there's
a choice for them to have that job and
what so I appreciate that minute yeah
that's a good uh yes people do try to
make it real racial you know people do
people try to make it racial yeah yeah
cops wake up and they're all different
color people two cops come in all
different shades
you know the George Floyd um the
gentleman's that that took his life I
mean that had the main man and he looked
white as a white guy thing Calvin and
then they had
then they had another guy a black
gentleman and then they had another
white tall guy
maybe Dutch practically and then a
Vietnamese guy
TomTom I think so they have a multitude
you know it's you know it's it's uh yeah
it's not a it's not like it's white cops
versus people of color you know and I
believe yes some people try to turn it
into that it's it's police brutality and
I think it happens sometimes because and
I could be wrong and I probably am wrong
but I think it happens sometimes because
you have more poverty in diverse
communities you know and I'm sorry to
say that if you you know if you were
extremely diverse and it you know it
hurts you to hear that uh you know I
don't mean anything by it I'm just you
know and statistically that it's tougher
it's tougher so in the end I think it
even comes even into a poverty a lot of
wealthy black and Latino people having
trouble with that as much trouble with
the police like actual to the point
where you're seeing death now you still
probably have more racial profiling but
I don't know you know I don't know all
the statistics on that and I'm not
trying to get into that you know um but
yeah it's interesting I don't know if
we--if making it out to be a race thing
doesn't help I think and there's two
things that's going on you know you see
a lot of race stuff going on and you see
things that are just really focused on
police brutality this next gentleman
that called in the his head is tight man
like my hair is so long right now I
gotta get a ding
but I appreciate you calling ma'am you
know this next gentleman called in and
this this guy had a suggestion that I
thought was super interesting let's take
it right here guy you know what I feel
rich Raleigh North Carolina rich out of
Raleigh Raleigh rich huh rich got that
cash rich got them coins baby bankroll
Richie huh Ritchie with that bread huh
stacks on stacks on stacks rickety
rackets wrecks Richie right there is
Richie rad Richie with them right thanks
Albert Hey look at the former 82nd
airborne paratrooper served in Iraq
twice Afghanistan lose and there was
angry mobs and unfortunately that's how
you you calm down
disobedience was with a hammer
people all like that so what I was going
to say was you know I'm not a mayor and
police chief Elizabeth you had female
between is being down in certain
citizens prevent any kind of
investigation or anything you know
misbehavior then they happen we had a
female that conducted the search here
that handled that and maybe this was you
know it has to come down to there's a
black you just need more black top black
top black top deal with the black people
perpetrators whatever black gladiator
gang brother thank you for the call
that's it that's that's um you know
that's something to think about there I
was
thinking about this as well man what if
you call a police station you say hey
you know I have you know I got two white
guys over here
I got a you know I got one Latino and I
got a you know one Neapolitan you know
and that's who so that's they send you
that that style of officers then you
have just to find a way to take the race
element out of it you know to take it
and to make it not a you know to make it
not a racial thing it'd be interesting
you know you like a can you send
somebody over yeah I need a guy I got a
Dutch somebody over here that's Dutch
and I got a mm2 vietze over here you
know throwing rocks and they're like oh
[ __ ] we understaffed over here all we
got is you know we have a black guy and
we have a Croatian female I don't think
we can help you we can't help you
tonight you know that'd be crazy
wouldn't it but would that be
interesting if they had you know if they
had certain ethnicity alter you officers
you match it up you match this you match
that you know I'm just thinking outside
of the box here thinking of different
ways because if if things continue to be
a problem then then you have to try and
you know think of some different options
you know like I used to work at that
place what was that place called in
Charleston it was called a frozen
options and you could get a different
something a little you know frozen candy
or a frozen ice treat or something and
get you something get you a little
cousin a little you know grape something
low eskimo sour sauce or something
zipper
what else we got man let's hit this
other call that came in right here again
it was socio my name is Eric I live in
Sacramento California
sorry post on Instagram No thank you for
calling Eric and yeah post on Instagram
if you have thoughts about what's going
on to give a call man I know I mean
after I found it so hard to try and
there's just not a lot of room for
communication out on social media it's
al it's not it didn't feel very
welcoming and we got so many calls at so
many calls onward know it's crazy out
here man
I live I actually work in a police
department not as the officers as a
janitor and you know I've been a big fan
of the podcast and keeps me motivated
keeps me working but anyway yes thanks
man and congratulations on your work
over there you know it reminds me of
that movie Good Will Hunting and that
you know that guy was a janitor for a
little bit in them BAM he's uh you know
he's driving an El Camino out you know
any going to get the girl
so Gangrel more and then I'm like I'm
here and I'm just kind of walking around
doing my own thing and you know I
oversee a college some cops talking [ __ ]
about what's going on and like bashing
other people and I hear two other cops
like you know just being you know a
little bit more mindful about what's
going on you know I know that a lot of
people say that all cops are bad but me
working here I've been working here for
a little bit over a year and I think
it's pretty safe to say that really if
not all cops are bad there's some that
are full of big that to me I'm a Mexican
and they do me mug you know the they me
mug me and they give me thirty bucks but
there's some that are trying to get to
know you trying to give you
opportunities and yeah man that's crazy
out here I hope everybody stays safe
gang brother thank you and Nash from BTS
the police department behind
scene so yes it's uh you know it's
heartbreaking man what happened to the
man and and George Floyd and and you see
him you know just the this stuff is
heartbreaking and it hits you in a place
where you know it just hits you in a
human it just hits me in a human place
and I don't think that that place that's
inside of me has any color in it you
know there's a place inside of us that
doesn't have any that doesn't even know
what color we are you know there's a
place inside of us that uh there's a
place inside of us that really I mean
just really can that that feels each
other's painting it's like a it's not
even our heart it's not our brain it's
just some I don't know what it is I I
don't even know if they have a name for
it I mean I know they have a name for it
like empathy or sympathy or
understanding but I don't know if they
have a name for this this I don't know
it's like a it's a place where when I
well you have it and and and when you
see pain it hurts even if it's not yours
you know and it hurts you at a place
that's deeper than your skin and bones
you know one thing I was thinking uh
before we get into this next call they
had was what if maybe it's time to kind
of rebrand the police you know maybe
it's time to have a to not have police
departments and to have just National
Guard or just you know a different type
of
just because I start to wonder how's the
des des police gotten too much of a
negative connotation with it now that it
just makes the whole job even tougher
you know it makes the whole job even
tougher that I don't I don't know if you
got a man out there and he's coming at
you know and you know and now you got a
different name you got a different color
suit you got a different you know I
don't know maybe you make it so the
weapon you got to answer a trivia
question or something for you can use it
or something you know you got a I don't
know but I'm wondering this if you know
if it's to police the police so for so
it's had too much of a it has too much
negativity with it attached to the name
not a test with all the officers but
just that it has too much negativity
attached with the name or too much bad
branding that maybe you do use a
National Guard or you use a military
police or something like that of course
you'd have to change their name I don't
know I'm just thinking out loud
and I don't have any right answers man
you know I thought it was beautiful to
see oh wait let me get this call while
we're on National Guard homeward as
going on Theo this is Andrew out of a
Virginia hey how's it going man I'm in
the military and I just want to bring
light to a you know a certain situation
I don't think anybody's really talking
about you know those guys in the
National Guard I'm sure they all want to
protest too but US military people were
held to a different standard we can't
really protest like everybody else
protest so it's federal charges at that
point they could take our livelihoods
away so wow I don't even know that they
yeah you see in National Guard's when
you see them you know court owning or
court on court owning off an area and
yeah you immediately I feel like people
immediately feel like oh these are the
bad
that's correct then that's crazy isn't
it that people immediately they'll see a
man in military yellow he that's the bad
guy that guy's just you or me they just
put a different outfit on him
and he has to do his job he can't even
protest if he wants to you know I didn't
know that man it's you know so it's like
there's feelings behind the the outfit
onward put that in your ear and see what
you think about you know the position
that they're in it's hard for us because
we can't even speak out on things like
social media and certain be caught out
in the streets like that because you
know they can catch us up and you know
I'm an avid listener of this past
weekend of king of the sting I'm a Theo
von fanatic I do well I appreciate that
man thank thank you bro thanks for the
thanks for saying some of that nice
stuff at the end and you know thank you
for your service man you know I it's
hard I'm sure it's hard for you guys you
know it's uh I'm sure it's hard it's how
you know things are hard for a lot of
people different things are hard for a
lot of people in and it is unfortunate
when you know there's that Chris Rock
bit going around you can't have a bad
apple on a police force you know you
can't
that's a job you just can't have it on
and I'm sure a lot of these forces they
don't want it to be that way you know
[Music]
but that that job has just got to be so
it that jobs got to be tough and it's
got to be really tough for a lot of
people now if you're some people might
be out there just wanting to be an
egomaniac and just wanting to play
Robocop and do this in that you know
it's unfortunate when you know there's
bad there's those
there's police officers that don't do
well and and that you know that uh that
use extra violence and extra brutality
and just enforce their will at a you
know at a unfair and even deathly amount
sometimes it's just his heart breaking
man I don't think anybody I don't know
anybody who doesn't agree that that's
heartbreaking you know uh it's
heartbreaking man but yeah you don't
know we don't know what these people in
the uniforms are thinking you know these
people are they don't even get to
protest if they want to that's kind of
interesting that you got a man right
there he can't even or a woman right
there
whose serve in the country and they
can't even protest if they want to what
else let's take another call that came
in right here onward do you man you're a
beast on the producer yeah I just these
rights man you crazy everything's crazy
right now it's crazy times I actually
you know I'm the eyes my stay rested
peace George Floyd justice for George
Floyd that man I stood on his neck with
his knee he deserves to be executed
that's a hundred percent fat
thanks me but I just want to say they
were riding on the Main Avenue you know
my neighborhood I was I was down there I
was right in the middle of all that just
watching and it was really heartbreaking
to see cuz I didn't get the vibes that
anybody was really out there protesting
it was more vibes of everybody's kind of
having fun in the chaos so pretty hard
breaking in the center of my city though
there it's mostly peaceful protesters
beautiful amen brother thank you for
that message and that's out of
Philadelphia that man called in and yet
to put the the protesting a lot of the
rioting I get the looting and stuff I do
not I don't get it I just don't get it I
understand that you know as people that
say that they you know they have nothing
and they can
you know I just don't get I just don't
get it
it just doesn't equate to me how you
know how you're burning down or how
you're taking from a small business
owner that kind of stuff I just don't
get it you know I just don't get it now
old navy [ __ ] break into an old Navy
dog you know what I'm saying dude break
into an old Navy because brah you'll
probably help the place out get in there
and help you know they just they got a
whole bunch of [ __ ] they selling an
errand steal that dog they always got
that little dog statue to steal that but
somebody using a flamethrower at a damn
DSW shoe store or [ __ ] uh hiding you
know put covering a Cinnabon or a shake
shack in a kerosene and lighting that
bad burger [ __ ] up I just what are you
doing that's not helping anything now I
do think though that people could have
chaos in them and they've been having it
pent up and then this is just a place
where you know it was a real perfect
storm for chaos to get out there we got
a call that came in right here here we
go all right man I live in Delaware
[ __ ] the [ __ ] first date
first right and we've been having all
these riots [ __ ] want to break
into the mall we only got two of them
you won't break into the closest one in
our in our state capitol like how do I
understand that they want everybody
wants like black rights and everything
but why are you breaking into the mall
there's any helping you yeah gang bruh
yeah man were you breaking into that
mall you know what I'm saying you
shooting up an American Eagle or
something or you be in there you throw a
hand grenade into an IR post ollie
right you blowing up a damn set of jean
shorts or something that ain't doing
nothing
you know you and there somebody throw a
bowling ball into a damn Claire's
boutique man that you ain't doing
nothing you ain't doing nothing but now
I understand a grinder stand aggression
I understand anger I understand now if
you don't have anything but I remember
when I was young and we didn't have
anything dog if so a little bit of chaos
started it's easy to just hitch a ride
on that chaos cart it's easy so you know
you have people that have been inside
for months
they can't even meet up as a group the
first thing they're allowed to do to
meet up as a group is burn down a dam
you know is burned down a dam um
whatever that place is called what is
that store in the mall where they you
can do that thing your face The Art of
Shaving bra and now if you want to get
in there and you want to you know take a
tommy gun to an Art of Shaving but I
love freaking load the bullets back
behind you but you over there you you
know you taking a chainsaw to frickin
lose its sandwich sandwich you know shop
or somebody selling homemade licorice
--is Orla choruses breath and you're
gonna run in there and you're gonna cook
you know shank somebody because they're
over there you know at the hot air
balloon outlet or whatever come on
you're gonna run in with Donna Karen
brought George floor didn't even wear
Donna Karen has nothing to do with them
but now I understand that if people get
upset enough and they don't get there
they feel like their voice isn't being
heard and they're like well how do i how
do I get my voice heard you know let's
hear more
here's another call nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three and
actually let me tell you right now thank
you for being here for this episode I do
want to tell you that you know thank you
for supporting my podcast and this
podcast in this group and our group and
um you know I I'm grateful for that man
I really am you know I don't know what I
would do if I didn't have this job right
now and you know you know you bet you
help make that possible you know and you
know I have friends that listen I that I
didn't even know you know it's funny I
was talking to a friend of mine the
other day a black friend actually and I
am black dropping right now my friends
staying and um you know he said we were
just texting and he said you know I've
listened to every episode of yours even
when you were doing two a week and and
that just hit me heavy man it hit me
heavy man to think that just that people
listen that people listen to me you know
[Music]
it just I don't know you know it made me
think a lot of stuff it made me think
man Wow
you know how much what do I do I live
what out what do I consume of my friends
you know am I paying attention to what
they're doing sometimes you know what do
I listen to of people that have a
different skin color than me you know am
i checking in with other stuff do I you
know what am i supporting
[Music]
but that was just you know that hit me
really in a you know it just hit me in
the heart you know in this whole witness
all of this stuff all of this stuff
going on let me get here let me get to
the side first and I'll get back into
this you know if you're struggling
people struggle and you know I'll be on
the struggle ship maybe and I'll be
saving room for you people struggle and
you can be one of those people as well
and if you are one better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
that's right you can start communicating
in under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online you know
sometimes you might live in an area
where like man I can't you know my
cousin's wife is the damn therapist in
town I can't go there you know or or
[ __ ] my wife is the therapist in town I
can't go there
she'll know now you you have the
opportunity to get therapy the service
is available for clients worldwide
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available that's right
you can communicate over text you can
communicate over FaceTime you can
communicate over the phone you know the
offer as many ways to communicate
they've got them and our listeners can
have a happier life today by visiting
better help calm slash Theo that's
better
h e LP and join the over 500,000 people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional that's right special offer
for this past weekend listeners get 10%
off your first month at better help calm
/th oh we're talking about oh I know
that you know I thought a lot of things
is you know I thought a lot of
once you know things got real racial as
well you know this past week things have
got real racial and and America is tough
you know America is a country that
that's that has diversity in it some
countries it's not like it's not like
that diversity is it's not easy
apparently apparently diversity is not
easy on planet Earth I'm not saying that
it's impossible or that is I'm not even
saying that it's hard but and I'm also
saying this is just my perspective man
you know I try to keep an open heart in
mind but it's hard I only have my own
experience with the world but you know
it's so but I definitely asked myself
this week I said well why am i racist
you know and it's a good question to ask
yourself man am I am i racist and what I
don't like is I don't like things you
see online it says if you have to ask
yourself than you if you have to ask
yourself then you are racist if you have
to this then this and that man stop stop
with that you're shutting down peoples
voices man that's the worst but yeah I
definitely asked I said man am i or do I
have racist ways that I'm not seeing I
know I have some behaviors you know I
feel like some of those are based on
experience on experiences you know um
you know I think I get nervous if I go
into a group where I'm the only one of a
certain ethnicity you know if I go into
a group of Mexicans are going to a group
of blacks or I go into a group of Asians
or are going a group of women you know I
go into any group I get
I do feel uh sometimes I guess it's a
nervousness sometimes it could be more
scared now I find no people in the group
and stuff that's different but I don't
feel that because oh I hate these people
or I have hatred I feel it because maybe
I maybe you've had an experience maybe
you walked maybe I'll you know when I
was young I got jumped by a couple
groups of guys who had darker skin than
me man you know and so I think you know
I'll probably have had experiences that
leave me you know kind of lead me to be
feeling a certain way sometimes but but
I think it's a good question to ask
ourselves man you know sometimes it's
like you're just you may have had
experiences that leave you feeling a
certain way but that doesn't make you
racist you know so I don't know it's
it's it's a lot you go online also in a
it's everything online is extremely you
know you feel white shamed a lot you
feel a lot of white shaming and I'm
shaving I don't like that [ __ ] man you
know uh and that's that's scary it's
scary to navigate okay is this just
something that I'm just do I just need
to stay off of this kind of social media
that you know what's going on here and
then also how do I not make this about
me this has nothing you know this is a
movement supporting black or people of
color Kent I don't know I don't even
know what to say sometimes but
supporting you know police brutality
it's confusing man is very confusing but
I do think it is a good idea to ask your
heart sometimes what's going on and I'm
grateful to protests like this and stuff
because it makes me do that
you know I literally I said man am I am
i racist you know where do my racial
experient what where do my experiences
come from with race you know it's
interesting to think about those things
um what else we got man we had some
beautiful calls that came in sorry to
just be going through calls this week
but you know I'll put on Instagram and
so many calls came in that uh that it
was a lot man that it was a lot here we
go right here the hotline is always
ninety five six six four nine five zero
three here in Virginia
what's up beat Kate let's hear it baby
thank you for calling sir George Floyd
murder hundred percent wrong peaceful
protests for equality 100% right rioting
looting hijacking the movement of the
peaceful protesters hundred-percent
wrong as well and overwhelming majority
agrees time would leave the police
station like we do firefighters and EMTs
we'll call you if we need you that's an
interesting way that's an interesting
way of doing it you know we'll call you
if we need you leave them there you know
not having patrols as patrols make
people feel a certain type of way we got
this call that came in here from a young
lady where do we go right here what's up
Muriel thanks for calling San Diego down
there and I've been down a good place
too you know they got a lot of Bulldogs
uh doing sex down there you could you
know get you a little pit bull and get
you something you know get you a little
cuddle
get you a little slice of uh you know
they got hoagies and everything on their
tacos down there what I'm talking about
Pacific Beach get you a beautiful treat
all work time to speak up
[Music]
Mexican Americans very affected with the
whole thing going on and I'm speaking up
because I'll be mad if I hear another
white person honest to complain about
the riots being too much and saying that
there should be another way but I don't
think there is in the past in 2014
Kobe Bryant wore a t-shirt that says I
can't breathe and he got a lot of hate
for that and that was peaceful in 2016
the NFL took a knee during the national
anthem and you saw the backlash it will
continue and I think this is the only
way I believe that can really get under
people's skin and even if people are
complaining about the violence this may
be consider the fact that people of
color never fully felt a part of society
and people running neighborhoods may be
the one way to get to people who are
racist thank you for that call young
lady appreciate it
I believe that's a young lady you do not
know on a percent but I'm gonna go I'm
gonna stick with that the assumption
there yeah you know it's you know it's
if you feel like you can't you're not
heard you know when busi was in here the
other day he said one thing that I
thought was interesting that he talked
about and thank you to everybody I got
so many nice messages man I was so
excited to have him in that I was so
excited in that
easy that when started this podcast I
talked about man if busi came in man man
it would be great could you even imagine
and then there he was man it was cool
too man
it was cool he was cool bruh it was I
was nervous I was kind of I mean I
wasn't well big baby said that he that
boo see that is a gangster so I was
definitely nervous that's what I was and
and he said something that was
interesting man he said that you know
about black people having their own
their own towns their own infrastructure
their own schools their own laws their
own their own you know everything their
own everything and when you just said
that to about people not feeling a part
of society you know that's interesting I
wonder if you know because there's
probably people that feel like that
there's probably of people that feel
like they would like to just have their
own society so it's like how do you get
that you know maybe there in the future
you know you have places where if people
want to just live with people like
themselves then they can and then that's
a choice you know and I'm not talking
about segregation I'm gonna talking
about anybody being forced to live
anywhere or I'm talking about if people
choose this is they all this is what we
want this is what I want I don't know
you know I don't know because America is
just a system it's just a you know it's
just a it's just a system and it's a
system that's always kind of changed
over time
and the more it gets diverse and the
more people stand up for what they you
know that groups protest it's gonna
continue to change you know it's kind of
like a chameleon I think I mean I like
to think of it as that you know and I'm
just there's so much there's so many
voices there's so many voices but I feel
like the protests and stuff this weekend
and last week seemed really magical a
lot of it you know seeing a lot of the
humanity just the people getting
together and you know it seemed a lot
more diverse than pictures you see a
protest of of other protests for me
anyway it seemed really I don't know it
seemed like a movement you know and I
think you have most people agree that
you know you want that people deserve to
feel safe in their country I don't know
what I'm talking about really uh but
yeah if you felt like you have not like
yeah what would you do if you feel like
nothing else is working to get your
voice heard
you know busi and i were also talking
about how atlanta now is such a
prosperous city for african americans
and i believe a lot of stuff is time a
lot of stuff is time and a lot of stuff
is money you know uh you know when I was
young I could relate a lot to poor black
children because they didn't have
anything like we didn't have anything
you know when it was such a uh you you
know they and then you get to places
like Atlanta and you really see like a
blooming prosper I mean it's just it's
it's great it's it's amazing it's
awesome but that's money
you know that's money mine uh what do we
got right here here we go
let's take a call that came in again hey
we've got the Maury all the way out of
Maine was Maurice from Maine and more
recent their baby and I'm frickin met a
girl up there
who let me touch that see Rotch one time
maybe I can't remember but but I
remember a bat was flying at us bruh and
we was up there in an abandoned house
and I hit that [ __ ] with a tennis
racket man not the girl the bat so that
little bastard look a little dirty
bastard that little [ __ ] air bastard
that little [ __ ] coughs Mugler came
at has run us I've clipped that [ __ ]
out the sky with that andre agassi
brought hit that bed John Oh words sir
real far other side of the country
you know I are pissed a lot of people
are upset well people have good reason
to be upset but the vast majority of
people are seemingly doing this looting
terrorizing vandalizing the facing of
property all that [ __ ] seems to be just
a way to put themselves out on Instagram
or social media to get attention you
know to be part of the group to be one
of them you know stand out even though
everybody's doing the same thing what
people do have a reason to be upset and
some of this will help will change some
of it won't
a lot of it's just going to be awful tax
money through the through the drain down
the drain but that's what I feel it's a
little crazy out here but I'm ready for
that bugaloo let's do it Gang Gang Gang
man thanks for calling yeah so you know
I I don't know man I don't know how you
get
you know I don't know really if there is
a solution it's just a slow evolution
and and I think that awareness is key
and you know I definitely think yeah a
lot of people out there for social media
a lot of people trying to get social
media just trying to just get the right
thing the right picture the right well
for one the right thing to express what
they're feeling and understand that but
other stuff yeah people just trying to
you know I'm trying to get my cousin the
[ __ ] you know hit somebody with a
skateboard who's stealing a bag of
oranges and [ __ ] and you're like damn
man that's crazy bro you know that's
really some don mattingly citrus type
[ __ ] right there man but yeah let's take
this call came in man and I felt like
that a little bit with this call right
here here we go hey this is about the
protest in Atlanta the protest black
city can't believe I got home safe
tonight we don't know what the next you
know the next step kind of thing is like
how does this all end and we were asking
police to just say the word black life
matter or just taken me and they refused
and I was looking them straight in the
eye and they were looking back at me
with what kind of a look of just like
you know why I'm not going to say it
like they were racist and so that I mean
we just have to keep pushing because you
they have to be able to say it right I
don't know why they won't they won't
respond I don't know why they just
refused to respond we're supposed to be
a team yeah I mean that's interesting
kind of you know that I don't know if
on-duty police officer I mean trying to
get them to do something you know I just
don't I mean that sounds like it's
something for you
you know I don't know trying to get an
on-duty police officer to take a knee or
do blacklivesmatter that sounds like
it's something for social media
you know that man's at work and also
he's at a stressful probably the most
stressful day at work he's ever had and
trying to get something for social media
it's just you know or that doesn't make
him racist because he doesn't want to be
a part because he chooses not to that
means working he's at work
you know maybe catch him when he's off
of work and talked to him and then
police officers I don't know if they can
just be racist like this man saying like
police officers aren't just blue you
know they're police officers are every
color and every type of person you know
one of my good friends red grant his
wife is a police officer you know if you
watch that television show it's called
it's a show for TV it's a TV show it's
called um where the water where they
couldn't drink it where you boil daddy
longneck is from Oh grant no murder no
it's damn boy
let me see this [ __ ] don't drink the
water we can't drink it
Flint it's called the Flint police show
basically something like that Flint PD
or something and it's just interesting
it's interesting to see what there's
what those people's lives are like all
the time you know it's real interesting
to see but yeah I mean I don't know if
you know I think that would be the best
thing is to catch them off duty and see
how they feel but they're it's very
diverse these police forces most of the
police officers that I see here in Los
Angeles are probably Latinos you know or
make on us do one thing that gets on my
nerves when somebody is Mexican and
people call him Spanish dude don't do
that [ __ ] Spanish brah he's Mexican
don't do the Spanish thing they come on
that guy in Spanish that guy's a Mexican
guy have some respects again you know
for the Mexicans man Spanish dude that's
some [ __ ] this is my Spanish friend
somebody said one time dude you don't
know [ __ ] that ain't your [ __ ] friend
if you don't know you're your boys
Mexican right there that's an hombre
Papa just that kind of stuff man um what
else man oh let's get into one or two
more calls man yeah sorry to focus just
on this stuff this episode but I felt
like you know I committed to it by
having people call the hotline and um
and and so I wanted to honor that but
yeah I don't know if trying yeah it's
just I don't know man
I don't know it's a touch it's a choppy
time there's a choppy time
let's take another call that came in
right here hey Theo its Miller calling
from Canada you told us that we can now
leave a comment on all this protesting
what we think of it and you know I'm a
white kid from a small town and I always
grew up feeling like I was lacking a
certain perspective so I moved to a big
city and I studied criminology for four
years and you know I haven't really been
saying much on social media these days
because I just feel like everyone should
tend to their own garden and you know I
don't want to tell anybody else what
they should or shouldn't be doing but
I've gotten some comments from people
saying you know oh you know violence is
a inherent form of racism and stuff and
you know like a lot of people don't know
other stories I I spent fifty thousand
of my own dollars and four years of of
hard work to to better understand and
gain a better perspective of what's
going on in minority communities and and
their experiences with police and you
know I hope to be a police officer
someday and I just feel like doing
things like you know building a
relationship with this homoerotic man in
my community and and and mowing his lawn
you know that's uh I'm better suited you
know just focusing on myself and not
telling other people what to do so these
are so my thoughts thanks for creating a
space for us to to leave thoughts like
this and Gen gang gang brother yeah man
I think yeah I think that's one way to
uh to make things better is to try
things a little bit different you know
touch out you know touch a gay friend
you know touch a gay friend touched
touch them hug them hold her hand do
2-yard do something blow up uh you know
help help them help them do something
change the guard and change the house
you know get the mail get the mail for
somebody that's Latino you know or not
Spanish you know what I'm saying me
Ghana Papa you know do something nice go
and knock on that person's door or say
what's going on you know uh
this the the disconnect if 'ti these
days we do I think start to wonder more
we start to wonder am i okay are they
okay are they thinking these things am I
thinking these things you know you start
watching the news or you start getting
caught up and then I start wondering man
I don't feel good you know the news make
me feel like I'm a bad person you know
or the news just wants to keep showing
this same thing you know you got a call
check in with a buddy check in with the
friend say man this stuff had me
thinking about you you know and I'm
sorry it took for this kind of thing for
me to call but I just wanted to let you
know I just wanted to say hey you know
check in with somebody that maybe has a
different experience yeah I mean it's so
cuz I just there's so many good people
out there and it's wild to me that the
news makes money off of this whole thing
that's the craziest thing to that the
news is making money off of this and
they keep telling us this same story and
they don't and the news doesn't if you
just watch the news you think that
people are bad not crazy if you just
watched the news you think people are
bad
I just do not find that to be the truth
you know the only choice is to be
hopeful but thank you for the call young
man yeah 10 to the garden that you can
touch you know talk to your friends
communicate with people you care about
communicate with people that are
different than you you know take a
little take a ticket uh
you know take a couple take a thing a
soup to a black friend take a you know
take a piece of art to a Mexican friend
you know take oh do something you know
extend a hand a pat on the back just an
extra hey man you know just an extra
look in the eyes man a man I care about
you you know I care about that your
experience here on earth is good you
know if there's something that you feel
like I don't do personally that could
help that that makes it on good let me
know what's up but yeah I mean I don't
know I just have my own perspective but
I appreciate that people call and I
appreciate you know it's this is life
this is life and I choose a lot of times
also to see I'll see a lot of the
positive things going on you know I look
around and see a lot of good stuff going
on around in America for people of all
ethnicities I mean she every but every
music every so much music is black
influenced you know so many of the top
athletes entertainers I see a lot of
diversity people because that you can oh
you can pity you can say you don't know
you don't this and that and and it's
hard yeah
I can look at all that - but but that it
doesn't make me blind if I choose to
look on the bright side you know
sometimes it's like online like people
don't want to they don't want to hear
you they want to control you
that's something I didn't like on social
media people want to control you they
want to control you man
no this is what you say this is how you
say it I'm not a part of that whatever
this this uncomfortable thing is where I
don't get to be myself where you're not
you where I'm not I'm just a piece of
some fictional puzzle that you know
that's is that doing anything I don't
know man I'm thinking out loud I'm sorry
if I'm complaining a lot or something I
don't know what's going on I should
probably go home soon we got one more
call that came in from this young fella
in North Carolina gang going through a
rough time recently and then trying to
keep the booze brother thank you for
calling Eric man and I'm sorry to hear
that you're having trouble with the man
I know that uh I know I know some stuff
about that
onward just Cantina buddy myself through
it
mauriz inside cases it's like a Richard
Pryor's joke your first heartbreak the
first everything I was with the same
girl for seven years we broke up
abortion we know I'm running back to the
same issue as always just hope their
coping mechanism I had essentially just
the heartbreak just
The Betrayal feeling of how everything
then changed from one second to another
man I can relate to that feeling wins
when you part ways with somebody
especially when you're young and man it
feels like you have nothing man it feels
that is such a if you're really
sensitive like I was when I was young
and still him god man that's a deep it's
a deep cut when you're young
um word how your world can just shatter
and everything just falls apart I'm
trying to get clean I'm trying to do
everything right I got hooked on meth
and coke from a young age but the age of
14 I moved down to Mexico and just
really [ __ ] me up you know just all
messed me up and right now I'm trying to
get clean I'm trying to everything or
ten you get out of bed I can't do
anything I can't bring myself to go to
word come up the way knows I have a
little money put up I'm at the point
knows just my whole world collapsing and
I want to understand I've heard your
podcast in the past foot and I've
listened to you throughout the years I
saw you and Charlotte I saw you do all
of that and it's just an amazing person
I wonder how you can remain so
charismatic even when you've gone
through so many hardships to let you use
your addiction you overcome in it your
father's death and everything and hey
brother I appreciate your call man let
me uh see if I can call you
get you on that line baby get something
real going on here you know we're about
as real as I can get since you over
there in North Carroll at 9:00 hey Eric
man what's up bruh this is Theo I got
your voicemail man I just wanted to say
thanks for the voice mail yeah
man uh yeah I just wanted to I just
wanted to chat with you bro if you get a
chance man give me a call back my number
is it's the number that I text you from
as well yeah man I just yeah your voice
message was
I just appreciate it bro you know it was
uh yeah let's just circle up man
hit me up all right yeah oh man um yeah
what else you know I know a lot of
people out there are uh you know I know
it's been a hectic week and you know on
there's so much involved if you really
get into the racial side of things and
I'm not discrediting any of that or
discounting any of it you know I
appreciate everybody's calls and
everybody's thoughts with so many points
of view you know and I didn't want it to
get it too heavy where you know uh where
people get angry there's so many people
think about a lot of different things
you know but I believe in the end you
know I just believe the only thing we
can do is just you know one step at a
time and you know I was talking to my
friend Glen and he was saying you know I
think that good is gonna come from this
and I agree I agree
you know believe that good is gonna come
from this you know after tough things
and after tough things good stuff
happens you know that's how you know
nothing changes if nothing changes you
know and sorry I don't have a ton of it
you know introspection for you guys uh
you know I've been thinking about you
know what people's lives are like you
know I've been wishing that we could
have more honest conversations about
stuff you know we could have more you
know real dialogue about things you
don't see it that much in the news they
can't do it and so maybe we'll get into
more some of that stuff next week or in
the future overtime you know if you had
some thoughts or suggestions or
constructive criticisms about this
episode you can always hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three you know that's all I really
got man that's all I really got over
here
with something sweet that could take us
out today man and yeah I think just just
us trying to tap into that part inside
of us that doesn't have a color and you
know if you have it in you already you
know if you already spent time hovering
over that place
you know uh you know I think that's a
good place and I think it that that
place is is really it's really big
inside a lot of us I really do believe
that let's go out with a little leaven
Bartels man he's always got something
beautiful going on and uh and this song
I feel like you know was always
something special for me you guys be
good to your salesmen you deserve it and
and just know that uh you got this you
know take care of yourselves you know
let's let's let's tend to that garden we
can touch you know man if we all did
that or what if we all prayed at the
same time if we all prayed to a higher
power doesn't have to be a specific one
but if we all just you know what what
could happen you know maybe the world
cracks open then and and you know and we
all get the candy you know I mean cuz it
you know we're all barreling towards
beige man this beige power man it's all
in for decades it's everybody's Patrick
my Holmes that's a hit everybody's a
Super Bowl MVP man that's what I believe
you guys take care of yourselves man
[Music]
and this song really gets me man
Evon Bartels promised land as his EP
could see
100 miles away
baptizing empty Skyland with the whole
better days then I tell myself this will
be fine
[Music]
then I'll chew
I built inside my mind
[Music]
let's walk will fall from
every time
under
I'm just a child
for
[Music]
you did
g40
[Music]
I was you
I wish i
[Music]
you